- [Narrator] China's army of
snow guns is paving the way
for a smooth Winter Olympics.
It's the first games to
rely entirely on fake snow
and Beijing isn't the first
host city to make fresh powder.
Others have done it too,
supplementing real snow on mountain tracks
for the world's best
skiers and snowboarders.
- For producing artificial snow,
they require huge amounts of water.
It's nearly 2 million
cubic meters of water.
- [Narrator] That would be enough to fill
about 800 Olympic size swimming pools
and trying to access that
amount in a water scare city
isn't the only feat.
Snowmakers also have
to battle the elements.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] This isn't
just a challenge for China
because as the world gets warmer,
other host cities may not be cold enough
and end up using more artificial snow too.
We take a look at the logistics
and environmental impact
behind China's snow making process
to see what means for the future
of the world's biggest sporting event.
The first hurdle China needs to clear,
make sure there's enough
water to make snow.
The games are divided into
three zones that are in an area
with low precipitation during winter
and not ideal for creating
alpine conditions.
- Because it's one of the
driest region of China
that's already suffering
from severe water stress.
- [Narrator] Carmen De
Jong is a geographer
who's been studying artificial
snow's environmental impact
not just at the Olympics
but also ski resorts and
indoor sporting venues.
- So there's not enough
water available locally.
It has to be transported
from very far away.
- [Narrator] De Jong says one
of the zones sources water
from reservoir 18 miles away
and supplies nearby farms and residents.
And some parts of that
route are on an incline.
- They've had to build pumping stations
to pump the water uphill
to reach all the snow
guns and snow cannons.
So all the Olympic ski runs have pipelines
running underground to supply with water
and electricity in order
to manufacture the snow.
- [Narrator] This is an
energy-intensive process,
according to sport
ecologist, Madeline Orr,
who wrote a report about
the impact of climate change
on the Winter Olympics.
Take, for example, covering
one track from top to bottom.
- The amount of snow guns that
would be needed to produce
the snow for that for a
day is roughly equivalent
to a small apartment building.
- [Narrator] This entire process
requires closed supervision
and China has created
its own snow making team.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Since 2017,
these scientists have been
developing artificial snow
that would be suitable for the region.
- [Carmen] The soil is so dry
that the artificial snow
doesn't stick to the ground.
There's also the problem
of a lot of evaporation.
- [Narrator] De Jong says
a way around this issue
is injecting water into the soil,
creating a frozen layer optimal
for fake snow to then stick.
- (speaking in foreign language).
- [Narrator] The region is
also prone to strong winds,
which doesn't help when it
comes time to spray the area.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] As much as
Beijing or any future host city
may want to control the weather,
sport ecologist, Madeline Orr says,
there's no amount of artificial
snow that can make up
for the lack of cold.
- The problem is there is
no perfect sustainability
when you're producing a winter event
in a summer destination.
And so, no matter what you do
to be more energy efficient,
the design of the event is unsustainable.
- [Narrator] The Beijing
Organizing Committee
says artificial snow
making has minimal impact
on the local water supply,
because it uses a water
conservation system.
The International Olympic Committee
said it's treating climate
change as a serious challenge
and that artificial snow
production should be sustainable.
It said host regions must have
sufficiently cold temperatures
and will be required
to be climate positive.
Orr says the best option
may be to not choose
a future location like Beijing.
- It's okay to supplement
with artificial snow.
Some athletes like that it's extra speedy,
but it can't be a hundred percent again.
(light music)